.
>> DON'T RUN, JOE.
MARIE.
>> Marie: I KNEW THAT YOU ARE
TURNING TO THE RIGHT.
I COULD FEEL IT HAPPENING.
>> Kennedy: IT IS SO CATCHY.
SING IT WITH ME.
>> Marie: I'M NOT GOING TO
SING IT WITH YOU.
IT'S NOT JUST REPUBLICANS.
64%.
JOE BIDEN HAS REPEATEDLY DEFIED
THE POLITICAL ODDS.
HE BEAT ALL OF THOSE DEMOCRATS
IN THE PRIMARY.
HE BEAT DONALD TRUMP HANDILY.
HE AND HIS ADMINISTRATION AND
THEIR PARTNERS AND CONGRESS DID
SO WELL IN THE MIDTERMS COMPARED
TO WHAT PEOPLE THOUGHT SO I
THINK THE BIDEN TEAM.
>> THEY DID A REALLY GOOD JOB
LOSING, YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> WE GAINED SEATS IN THE
SENATE, GOVERNOR'S MANSION,
LEGISLATURES AND WE BARELY LOST
THE HOUSE.
I THINK THE BIDEN TEAM FEELS
LIKE BECAUSE OF THEIR SUCCESSES
AND LEGISLATIVE WINS, THAT THEIR
PARTIES VERY SQUARELY BEHIND,
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'VE BEEN ON A
WINNING STREAK AND THEY FEEL
PRETTY EMBOLDENED.
HAVE A QUESTION IS, JOE BIDEN
NOW HAS A RECORD THAT DEMOCRATS
REALLY LIKE AND A LOT OF
INDEPENDENTS LIKE.
WHO ELSE IS THERE THAT DEMOCRATS
WOULD WANT TO CHALLENGE HIM?
I DON'T KNOW WHO THESE PEOPLE
ARE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT CATCHY.
I THINK JOE BIDEN CAN WIN AGAIN
AND I THINK HE'S GOING TO RUN.
>> Kennedy: GOD HELP US IF HE
WINS AGAIN.
>> Emily: THE ONLY COLUMN THAT
HAD MORE THAN 64%, NO, WAS THE
HELL KNOW.
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS.
I THINK IT'S AN EMPEROR'S NEW
CLOTHES SITUATION.
WHAT MARIA IS ARTICULATING,
GOD BLESS YOU, PART OF --
IT'S THE PARTY LINE AND THE
QUESTION IS WHO WOULD BE THERE
TO CHALLENGE HIM?
THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S A REALLY NARROW BENCH
FRANKLY AND THE BEST OF WHAT'S
AROUND, TO QUOTE DAVE MATTHEWS,
IS KAMALA?
THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER FRESH
HELL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO DO BUT THE FUTURE LOOKS
BETTER ON THE G.O.P. SIDE.
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES FROM TOP TO
BOTTOM.
JOE BIDEN STRIKES ME AS A CROSS
BETWEEN MEGHAN MARKLE.
EXHAUSTED FROM PUBLIC SERVICE?
HOW ABOUT AN NYPD OFFICER,
BORDER PATROL, A MILLION OTHER
PEOPLE WORKING IN HER SERVICE,
SERVICE FOR THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA WHO DON'T COMPLAIN AND
AREN'T EXHAUSTED BY THEIR
SERVICE.
AND THEN A LITTLE BIT GISELLE.
I SUPPORT YOU.
OH, I DON'T.
THE TOM BRADY THING.
RETIRE.
NO DON'T.
NO.
IN JUST OVER A PERIOD
>> Kennedy: I DON'T BLAME HER.
SHE HAS TO SAY THIS BUT
DR. SIEGEL, THE PRESIDENT WAS
ADDRESSING LEADERS FROM
DIFFERENT AFRICAN NATIONS.
I KNOW DEMOCRATS, THERE IS SO
MUCH WINNING, THEY ARE ALMOST
TIRED OF WINNING.
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF THESE COMMENTS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I TOLD SOME OF YOU, YOU
INVITED ME TO YOUR COUNTRIES.
I SAID BE CAREFUL WITH YOU WISH
FOR.
I MAY SHOW UP.
POOR RELATIVES ALWAYS SHOW UP.
WEALTHY ONES NEVER SHOW.
THE POOR COME, THEY EAT YOUR
FOOD, STAY LONGER THAN THEY
SHOULD.
I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
MANY OF YOU AND YOUR HOME
COUNTRIES.
>> Kennedy: HE'S GOING TO EAT
ALL THEIR FOOD?
THE PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY
AMASSED A $16 MILLION FORTUNE IN
JUST TWO YEARS POST VICE
PRESIDENCY.
HE IS TRYING TO PAINT HIMSELF AS
A POOR PERSON TO AFRICAN LEADERS
WHO, THEY HAVE 140 MILLION
PEOPLE ON THE CONTINENT WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM FOOD INSECURITY.
A LITTLE INSENSITIVE AND THE
LITTLE 90, RIGHT?
>> Marc: IT'S DEFINITELY A
DISCONNECT.
OBVIOUSLY NOT SOMEONE WHO'S
SHOWING THE COMPASSION AND THE
EMPATHY HE NEEDS FOR PEOPLE IN
AFRICA WHO ARE STARVING.
THAT ACTUALLY MAY NOT JUST BE
INSENSITIVITY.
I'M NOT CONCERNED ABOUT HIS AGE.
I'VE BEEN ON RECORD A LOT ABOUT
THIS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S AN ISSUE
BEING 80 YEARS OLD.
I THINK IT'S A QUESTION OF HOW
SHARP HE IS.
I'LL THINK WE'VE GOT TO SEE
THEIR RECORDS.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN A PHYSICAL THIS
YEAR BUT LAST YEAR NO COGNITIVE
ASSESSMENT.
THE NEUROLOGIST SAW HIM ANY SIGN
OF PURE WE ARE NOT GETTING A LOT
OF INFORMATION ABOUT THIS.
SO MANY SO-CALLED GAFFES BUT
SOME ARE VERY SUSPICIOUS.
READING OFF A PROMPTER AND
SAYING "END OF THE LINE" WHEN HE
REACHES THE END OR FORGETTING
WHERE HIS SON DIED ACTUALLY.
BEAU BIDEN.
ALL OF THIS IS VERY CONCERNING
FOR THE POSSIBILITY THAT HE MAY
NOT BE SHARP ENOUGH COGNITIVELY
TO GO AGAINST PEOPLE LIKE PUTIN
OR CHAIRMAN SHE OF CHINA.
THE ISSUE IS WE HAVE TERRIBLE
PROBLEMS FACING THE WORLD RIGHT
NOW.
IT'S NOT GOING TO STOP HIM FROM
RUNNING.
I DON'T THINK THE AMERICAN --
DOESN'T THE AMERICAN VOTER GET
TO SAY HOW FIT HE IS.
>> Lili: I'M A NUMBERS PERSON
IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN.
I FIND IT FUNNY THAT OUR
FOX POLL IS MORE KIND AND THEN
THE CNN POLL THAT HAS 47% OF
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS WANTING
SOMEONE ELSE BUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN, SAME THING WITH
THE CNBC ONE.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
ANY GOOD STRATEGIST WILL FOLLOW
THE EVIDENCE AND THE NUMBERS
HAVE SPOKEN.
IF THE NUMBERS ARE THIS BIG,
MUST BE PLANNING ISSUE, LACK OF
A PIPELINE, WHO IS A VIABLE
CANDIDATE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
SO LET'S STAY WITH THE
STATUS QUO, NOT MY WORDS.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING.
I DON'T KNOW WHO'S LOOKING AT
THESE NUMBER